[Music]
so the trailer was shown and there is a
lot of noise in the internet but one
United voice was the loudest amongst all
and that is where is shimu in fact his
tease in the Call of Duty game was the
main reason why fans all over the world
initially became excited for gxk well
back then it was known as GVK part two
so let's talk a little bit about this
Titan the rumors and whether we saw him
or hints of him in the trailer also
we'll discuss a bit about his powers and
role in the hollow Earth let's do this
anyway firstly what do the rumors say
about him as far as the information
leaks the toy leaks and the early
screenings are concerned shimu is a very
powerful entity that has been in a dant
state for a very long time he is
supposedly the first ever Titan and
through him and his power powers are the
other monsters and creatures made into
Titans themselves he has ice powers and
was the one responsible for the L Ice
Age probably the last time he was active
and therefore we can infer that it is
during this time that the ancient war
the Titan war ended and the Kongs fled
to Skull Island he is also rumored to be
bigger than any previous Titan if not in
height than in length and overall body
Ms so the first question that everybody
is asking is where in the world is shimu
in the trailer was he shown in it or was
he edited out well I will let you in on
a secret remember the first trailer of
Godzilla versus Kong the part where we
just saw a split second glimpse of Mecha
Godzilla and die heart fans were able to
pause and Scout him
out Godzilla and Kong the new Empire is
directed by the same guy Adam windot and
on the same timing in the trailer we are
shown a glimpse of what is supposedly a
hollow Earth entry point in Giza near
the pyramids so this only goes to show
that The Vortex scene in the trailer is
something brand new I could almost say
it was created by something maybe a
Titan that has as yet unknown abilities
so that may be the first hint of shimu
shown in the trailer the second hint at
the presence of shimu is the cave that
Kong went into there we could see two
types of crystals one which is blue and
the other which is pink in color but
also skeletal remains of dead Kongs in
it
this teases the possibility of a
predator that hunts the giant apes or
these Kongs are sacrificed to him by
another namely scar so the third hint at
his presence in the hollow Earth is the
fact that Godzilla was encased in I
before he broke out with his new evolved
Pilla form the rumors and leaked info
state that shimu has the elemental
powers of ice and Frost and there is no
way that Godzilla with his Atomic nature
and reptilian biology could generate a
Crysis made of ice for him to cocoon in
and evolve we have seen him before
hibernating and revitalizing and it was
in a radiation filled underwater layer
which is in fact extremely hot therefore
in the movie we could see Godzilla well
this is a theory that we could see him
in his Super Saiyan blue form and then
he would be defeated and trapped in ice
by shimu then later by some means he
would get access to the Ping Hollow
Earth radiation and he would evolve into
the pink form the super saiyyan Rose
form probably of greater power and
therefore rivaling shimu in strength but
now another question from a lot of merse
fans arises and this is does shimu
really even exist or are the early
screenings and leaks wrong what if they
are mistaken with an evolved Godzilla so
what are the similarities that the new
Godzilla the pink form has with shimu at
least with his Call of Duty cave
painting silhouette and the rumors of
his ability ities well to start with
godzil broke out from Ice and was seen
in an ice crysalis so this could be
mistaken for his ice powers another
similarity is the presence of spikes in
his tail just like shimu the third point
is pilla's straighter crystal-like
dorsal blades which resemble the
straight spikes of shimu in the cave
painting and lastly Godzilla's new
physique with longer arms ttin legs and
no belly whatsoever resembles what is
shown of shimu in C so the probability
of Godzilla actually being mistaken for
shimu is something that raises a lot of
eyebrows but personally I believe that
even if he evolve to look like shimu I
think that is his Natural Evolution
pathway to become like the father of
titans the primordial one maybe later he
might become a Titan that is similar or
something that looks really alike with
shimu maybe that is the destination of
his evolutionary pathway now let's take
it for granted that shimu is another
Titan another monstrous en which is
apart from Godzilla what will be his
place in the hollow Earth his status and
role in the movie and is he more
powerful than Godzilla himself so as to
our theories on scar ruling the other
Kongs by forming an allegiance with the
Titan shimu we can say that shimu could
really be a very dark entity something
truly in power but from the Shadows
avoiding open Conflict at first CU he
might risk a coalition of other Titans
together banding against him
which could have been the case for the
ancient Titan War and why he was sent to
a dant state in any way he would still
hold a great spot as the apex predator
of the region an alpha Titan and
probably more powerful than Godzilla in
his blue form but as to how he would
Fair against a more powerful evolved
pinkzilla that is up to April 12th to
tell us if you like this video then
watch this other one as well and do
check out our Channel we might just have
things that you haven't seen before
especially about the monsterverse like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video take care fam